what is going on there reject nation we
got coy with us today to watch the final
episode of miss marvel what where's jon well
i killed him nikoi has finally replaced him
just like you all fears have come true you
manifested them you did this john is out of
commission he got the uh vid diesel as i like to
call it he's doing fine he's boosted and vaxxed
uh but and we're pc hard and hydrated we took
multiple tests and we are fine we are we tested
negative so we're good now we are here to watch
the final episode of miss marvel you know it's
you can do everything you've always wanted
which is a take over chest everyone's like
taking over the channel here's step one step one
eliminate john leave a like that would be very
much appreciated also subscribe and click that
notification bell for something the koi's comic
corner we did that often we got a pretty epic
video coming epic one coming up for uh ranking
all the mcu films quite an excellent job on that
full-length reaction watch alongs where you sync
up with the time coder over at our patreon
for super sexy rejects uh that's where you
sync up with your own copy i think i'm said that
everything right the boys thank you let's get to
it wish john well in the comments so we're gonna
transfer the next stop and head up state okay
it's okay wasn't easy one kamala first got our
powers either they're just like that was weird we
live in new york in the marvel universe no jersey
the passer buyers on that subway station are just
chilling they're seeing some crazy another day in
the marvel cinematic universe his powers are comic
accurate to that and miss marvel's now mirror
his which is interesting i have an announcement
drake all right let's do forgiveness i'm
about to bear hero i am the light girl
nightlight oh my god i had no idea oh my gosh
are your powers limitless or do you have to
recharge oh actually also i have been dying
to ask you on eid did you drop that kid on
purpose or was that like a game time decision
big bro just because you you can do all
these amazing things doesn't mean that you
actually volunteer to go looking for trouble
right i don't think you raised me to sit by
and do nothing when i can help people
i miss the dad he's great yeah i love
that she has a family no one does yeah that's
true and they're all like yeah we accept this
have you heard from bruno no why i've been trying
to get a hold of him because circle cue exploded
kamala khan you're not going anywhere not
dressed like that here i got something for you
did she make her the costume that'd be so cool
no that'd be the ultimate family yeah you know
oh she's coming around oh
that's beautiful sign of character
i love that for this family
oh that's great i love that that's very touching
that's so touching she's the
first ipsu character that like
shares this yeah openly yeah to
this level like that's beautiful
i'm a superhero that costume looks great
oh that is so cool
let's give it up for the vfx
artist yeah give it a please please
when the coast is clear you guys head to the high
school and i'll call kamala why would we go to
high school because the only place guaranteed
to be empty on saturday it's true she's smart
this is an exciting episode
costumes in the first 10 minutes
good afternoon i'm gonna need to see everybody's
i geez that was not our first rodeo miss agent
i assure you damage control is only here to
ensure your safety this is not a racist thing
at all white woman this kid could put you all at
risk if you are abetting a potential suspect no
one will be on your side chic i don't need anyone
on my side for god is always right i don't have
time for chronic quotes excuse me actually that
was abraham lincoln racist dodc racist confirmed
it's good that they didn't hide out at that mosque
might have found them i know my mom would kill me
if she found that i had a boyfriend and that it
was that one did you hear that i'm a boyfriend
and you're both witnesses do you have
a body cam i'd love to have this one
nice yeah they were there take
clifton street whatever you do
avoid grant thank you why don't
they see that door sliding
ah they all marvel disguise nice
that's crazy these two are paired
up right now right and all brian
look at her go
what are you guys wearing what are you wearing
awesomeness i was just scared i thought
i'm okay we're okay tell her you love him
i feel like i'm being crushed from the inside out
yeah they're going to have heard that
it's nice to see a costume
that's not cgi at all yeah like
even the scarf it's a scarf it's a real
scarf i really need to get him out of town
i know someone who can get him out just get him
to the harbor by midnight okay thank you thor
captain marvish he knows he knows cat marvel
i tell you everything and this is the biggest
thing that's ever happened to you and you
didn't tell me so i mean maybe okay but
you like kind of hate superheroes i didn't want
you to hate me oh when hate me hate me it's um
i messed up i'm sorry geez i
love them such a good actor man
murder the dodc danish control
is here how do they even find us
it doesn't matter i'm the one they want you
guys should leave now before you get hurt i
already blew my apartment they invaded the mosque
twice they tried to trick me into giving you up
what are you doing here the
theater has good lighting
it's where i film my tick tocks nice so we
distract and stall for as long as possible
until we can get cameron safe uh yeah yeah excuse
me hey uh are you sure you have authorization
for any of this sounds good we'll keep
him busy while you run out the back
mom send me a watch out for
you um take it up with her
i love this episode we grab every
single fire extinguisher in school
very realistic you're on the softball team right
you and nokia grab as many balls as you can
is this gonna be like home alone what's
going on guaranteed i don't care if you
need another 10 seconds okay you're not
gonna get it evacuate now deever you hear me
i understand she's not gonna listen we're
in position do we have a green light
call in all additional units we have a villain i
think she's a skrull yeah let's go there i hope so
pretty hell bent on steamrolling over
our entire world with their realm okay
i just yeah to make it who are you
even doing my sister driving lessons
do you even like british break off
do not tell carmen that okay
not too well out of here i think you should
tell him now make it high stakes that way
he'll blow all these people up it'll go
well for you oh looks like we've got a bomb
the ultimate plan
those clubbing cops they
sent all of you just for me
nice okay so i'll play this live but i
don't know for a do do do that do now hey
it's so i'm at kohl's high school where damage
control is me and my friends totally surrounded
hey say hang on help i'm coming target
on foot get a red hoodie and a bait
robinson i'm pat nicholson
this looks like a lot of fun
oh no
chemistry yes
your mom died i thought you should know
oh my god is this about to happen hey you guys
i'm sorry bruno um there's a team agent's
heading down this way i'll keep them busy
okay come on come on i'm rooting for you
bruno that was that hurts he already lost
spiderman he can't lose thanks bruno did you
know that he was up for spider-man was he
yeah i'm so glad he gave this because he's
so good in this hey guys what's going on
oh god they are hurting him
[__] wow
wow there it is it's working
they hate my mom i miss my mom i want to talk
to my mom call my mom what happened to my mom
oh now she's protecting him my mother's dead
he's in chain i'm sorry stop right there
oh my god he's gonna break bad yep it's on now
oh [__]
i guess this leaves room for bruno
i don't know why i'm getting
like terminator 2 vibes for some
reason we go
oh damn is that what they use on the
hulk i think so that big like yeah yeah
unless it's a laser no yeah
wow this is so menacing
who is this [__] i think she's our skrull
she said i'm biggen did she
i think she said i'm bigging
whoa wild
slight scorpion king vibes but you know
the vfx artist i'm so happy with it
oh that's awesome
the camera
i love the variety and how he uses those
powers yeah there's like different weapons
extend yeah it's like carnage
magic
hero moment
oh yay she's a superhero
well that's not fun
so trippy yeah
oh wow it's like when strange in cases yeah
we're gonna have a conversation comrade
let's talk about this get to the harbor
i'll buy you time get to the harbor
they both got like great grasps
on their powers now don't yeah
she murdered that boy she ate him
that was amazing they're all with you
oh this is a spider-man yeah you're gonna have to
get through me you went against my orders publicly
and then you attacked a bunch of kids using our
name and you know what that means yes that means
that you're relieved of your duty a union is
going to fix your mess get out of there now
i would not want to get on his bad side
oh she doesn't even get to celebrate
with the crowd she can go back
today's news everyone keeps asking
me ruby ruby do you know who she is
if i knew who she was i wouldn't believe it
she looked so familiar that was the writer oh
really yeah oh that makes me happy what'd she say
when the jobs girls are the best in jersey city
freaking action superhero math skills but i don't
know where those skills went when she screamed
pizza for life celebrate our own superhero free
ice cream pizza after salah of course yeah don't
get addicted to social media the trap don't do
it it's not worth it people are saying about
my superpowers online yeah woodrow wilson's the
writer and she was the one that said real gw nice
now cat marvel where are you
i personally think this is a really solid
finale so far yeah this is actually really solid
hey bro what are you doing here whoa
oh my god this is really scary yeah right
yeah right
well you saved the world oh [__]
that's what kamal means in arabic perfect
but it will do it's more like
what's the word wonder marvel
i share the same name as freaking danvers
but you sure are and always have been
our own little miss marvel oh gets the
costume from the mom and the name from the dad
that's beautiful i love that
i love you i love you i cannot wait to see her
interacting with carol danvers in the movie
like tiana paris real estate and here
magic
absolute magic i will monetize my daughter
there's the shot of the poster shot
i like the costume a lot i
love it yeah it looks great
oh captain marvel's bunking with
her heard you like your name
when i compared you to the rest of
your family something still seemed off
kamala there's something different
in your genes like like a mutation
this is the first real like whatever
it is it's just gonna be another label
please please oh dude i think your
theory is going to come true dude
get in liz's we're getting schwarman
i love you they're making her a mutant
i said this would leave yeah yeah
you did you gotta watch that one
so missed mutation mutation that's crazy that's
wild right into a world that hates and fears
them through damage control that's just gonna be
another label oh dude do you what what video was
that i don't even remember i've been saying that
video there was a no you know it was a quiz cover
corner i don't remember i'll find it i was right
i don't remember the damn i was like holy [__]
this is like exactly how yes that's crazy that's
how we got x-men we're just trying to promote
koi's comic course yeah you should watch common
corner where i get right that was a solid solid
episode that was such a good finale i enjoyed
that a lot i think that and loki are the best two
finales it's gotta be a post-credits scene right
i imagine what video was that no memory of which
one it was was it the thunderbolts video yes yes
apartment damage control and all that yeah so do
you think comrade would be in the dodc no not the
dude sorry though thunderbolts comrade probably
not but i think he'll be one of the mutants that
is a villain like an early brotherhood
of evil mutants kind of thing yeah yeah
like you know setting up dates and fears
them like everyone shut up oh my god
called it how did she contact her no she is hurt
the band had pulled her out and
put her in oh [__] she's gone
that costume is great too the new one
oh yeah that's the most excited
i've been to see captain marvel
i was like cool that was spectacular i've just
been saying since last episode you know i kept
saying that we gotta get that captain marvel cameo
and so and the new suit i'm so happy to just get
my captain marvel there it is there's the
magic that's what we'll put in the thumbnail
people will love it people will be so happy
i'll be so like i wasn't gonna watch this
but now i don't think you spoiled it i think you
encouraged me to watch it that's what they'll say
yeah yeah they'll say that exactly all right man
well we got we got chit chat there's some stuff
to say you want to play back that q real quick
the what the music queue make sure i'm not crazy
yeah yes okay i'm not crazy all right well
we just played back the audio of it and
koi pointed the shot in between because you're
doing the tick tock really quick and you said
that the the music yeah and i i didn't hear it
i think i was just so excited to hear the word
mutation that that literally like the like the
x-men animated series it's so fun i love how
much uh marvel studios honors the x-men animated
series you know like you hear that tune in doctor
strange multiverse of madness for a little bit now
you hear it here is the indication of the mutants
they're bringing back x-men 97. yeah i don't think
it's a coincidence expert 97. well it's going to
be michael yeah uh i think expert 97 and what if
we're going to be interesting bedfellows because
i do think expert 97 is going to be canon and it
ties into the original x-men 90s animated series
guys we have mutants in the mcu and we've been
having a hang with one for six episodes yeah
i know that's kind of crazy like this whole time
we've had a mutant here so they didn't do terrigen
mist but they did mutants which is more linear to
be honest like i i like the inhumans but i love
the mutants i like the inhuman storyline and i
like the inhumans versus the mutants but it is at
the end of the day a way more streamlined version
to have a character we're invested in be a mutant
and i love that she's like just another
label i like that they are already like
nipping that in the bud and addressing the
world that hates and fears them from the jump
and yeah and this was the first show i mean
you know falcon winter soldier dealt with
variations of racism obviously but this one really
is a culture as a people really dealt with racism
a lot and so you know when knowing that what
x-men mutants allegories are so much for that
like oh you're planting the seeds for that what
better show than a show that deals with you know
surveillance in a mosque and people judging you
immediately and like you know a fairly racist
government government wanting to shut you down
and what you are and i've been saying it for
months and kids shouldn't have powers right stuff
so yeah like it's a threat to be born with that
also it activates puberty yes yeah this is she's
the youngest of the experts she's the youngest of
the marvel characters dude that's right oh snaps
and this is all coming in post snap so this is not
something that is i want to talk about the
actual episode but it is obviously the big thing
yeah so this is something that won't be you know
a combination of of like mutants from another
universe smashing here and it is that we are
starting mutation here in the mcu yeah and she's
you know the first character to be in reverence of
the characters we've had so far so i'm wondering
if it's something about the planet and like
things that have been happening that caused
mutation to occur like i'm wondering if it's
gonna be a ramification of the events of blank
because we're you know we're chronologically deep
into the mcu the mcu itself is 14 years old in our
continuity but also in universe she's old
enough to worship these characters because
they've done their deeds yeah so i'm wondering if
that's gonna be a thing where you know you have
characters that worship uh and then you find out
like oh the reason mutation exists is some [__]
wow it's kind of this is pretty cool so cool
it's funny that they they wrote this show off
so like a lot of people haven't been to the show
and they bring the x-men which is the number one
interview yeah yeah they bring the mutants in
i'm like oh damn the ending of this is a pretty
big setup it's the most important thing for a lot
of people and this show was extremely important
and now they got to watch it and also you know
i i do think that not many post credit scenes
for these shows lead obviously we were it was
it was safe to presume that captain marvel
would show up as a way to tease what's going
on what's going on in that post-credit scene
uh i think that the bangle brought her into
space maybe it matched its pair fascinating
i think decree lost an arm and another cree had
the bangle and she just got booted right into a
crease girl war oh damn i think she got [__] up
she got booted through a beverage [__] preschool
captain brother i was at a pre-school world
now i'm in a bedroom what gifts i see me all
over the walls i don't want to see what's going
on tiana paris maybe she's photon maybe she's
spectrum maybe she's captain marvel now we're
the marvels and then we got secret innovation
too not sure what accent though uh secret
invasion i think is gonna be with the marvel's
we just wrote it you're welcome uh i think
that uh melissa mccarthy is captain mark
she is she's all three of them yeah like
teddy murphy yeah i'm three women in shots
uh i think that the events of captain marvel 2 are
going to directly lead into secret invasion but i
also think that like this is going to be a movie
already in progress when we go that post credit
scene is i think a mid action set piece and i also
loved her new suit oh yeah yeah that'd be cool
would this be the first show to feature
a scene from a movie anyway i think the
scene like remember when civil war when we
saw bucky in his arm in the thing yeah then
we saw that scene i think that scene
we just saw is going to be from the
other side of the movie awesome i think
we're going to see brie larson get bloop
and you know yeah yeah that's going to be dope or
it just starts moments either way yeah it's either
directly in or we see you know what i mean
the audience is going to be there like i
didn't watch miss marvel that's on you it's on
you you should have watched it this is a weird
we got a spectrum we got ourselves a marble we got
a little mine we got a miss we got a captain k-pop
keep up with us i was so impressed with this
episode we should talk about the episode
um no mutants i do not envy anyone that didn't
stay up till midnight tonight because it's
gonna be trending all night like that you cannot
avoid that tomorrow that's a that's a hell of a
twist it's like it suddenly makes a lot of things
click that's what you want from like this kind of
landing right if you want a moment to be like
well of course and yet you also uh we didn't
see it well i mean i i'm gonna claim some credit
i did say this was coming i just didn't know it'd
be like with a music cue like i said this was
gonna be the show that led to x-men i've been
saying that for the last few months i didn't
know it was gonna be like mutation that's crazy
yeah that's right that's fantastic you thought you
think like oh in the next installment or whenever
it comes around then they'd show it but i didn't
think the show itself would set the groundwork
forward and like in in a way that really cues the
audience in yeah i didn't think we'd hear the word
yeah i know it's the first time we've
heard mutation other than like you know
that'll let there be carnage i mean cinema i uh i
do also think that there's an interesting aspect
of like told you so with kevin feige being like
this marvel's really important i really like that
saying that oh yeah yeah i also think that
this is the last show before comic con
so now we got gods and time travel and but think
about it like if you're going to announce it all
age and you're going to have a saturday crazy man
now this is the one that's 10 days before like i
said it's coming i like i and like they don't do
anything half way they don't schedule things like
a lot of times these things lead next to the other
the announcement of this show with the panel like
marvel doesn't need to go to comic-con they have
d23 you got a couple of weeks now yeah right
this is because of comic-con that like i mean the
comic-con i think is because of the show not the
other way around yeah i think that this episode
really stuck the landing yes you know a lot of
the times with these disney plus shows you end
up walking away feeling like because it actually
i thought earned when it got big haha big and i
think it earned when it got big with the action uh
and i know that people have their feelings about
the one division finale and 10 10 10 10 people
have their feelings about the one division
finale oftentimes we're left feeling like
that's pretty rushed they kind of tried packing
it you needed more episodes that's usually more
episodes three women italians very challenged
it's two in the morning wearing chocolate
guys you're annoying we're talking about
like some beautiful films he's always got great
like film perspective and he'd be interrupting our
like garish melissa mccarthy okay we bring the
important colors here there's a beautiful shot
in this where the camera actually goes under a
truck and then it like lifts and moves in a way
that i'm not sure how they shot it now what would
comrade you're talking about right where it goes
with his foot like and then she comes almost
like handheld like it starts off as a thing
that looks like it's on a crane and it's
actually like a guy's holding it yeah
it's i wonder if they did like a hidden swipe
there or something like that so impressed like it
looks like an old david fincher shot that would be
cgi where would like go through glass but instead
it couldn't be yeah because someone's wheeled
kid on the other side that's such a dope shot i
view i'm constantly looking at visual effects now
with marvel with a certain eye to go do they have
enough time to finish this doesn't matter i think
they did a great job you know like there are times
where it looks a little cheesy i think anything
stretch even though this is not full on like mr
fantastic stretch related that's still some of the
hardest technology i think you've got to pull off
anything with expansion of limbs or
anything like that even if you're
just kenny valley-tastic it's literally like
straight you're making a body amorphous yeah
yeah and i think the the the sequences with her
when she is in beginning i enjoyed them overall
i think no matter what even if sometimes effects
look a tad bit off i think that this episode was
all about the catharsis and the emotion behind it
more than anything else like you get such a great
wrap up i i love the wrap up here because you
had like a show in the beginning that was like
a teen show right like a teen high school show and
then next thing you know like you're in the middle
east for a few episodes yeah and then when you
come back to jersey they bring it all together
really well and in a very rewarding way ultimately
like i thought the emotion behind it was so
joyous a lot of the time and touching like the
fact that her family was the thing that gave her
because i i was always curious like how are they
going to tie this in with the pakistani culture
or even more make it full circle and then they
did it with even with the family being the ones
who give her the suit and give her the title as
well which we talked about from like how it was
in the first episode where they're like kind of
oppressive towards her ambitions and this whole
fantasy suits exactly she wasn't allowed to wear
superhero costumes they made her one and yeah then
they make her one it's like this feeling of uh
acceptance and she's been more accepting of uh
her roots as well and then her name being uh a
root to her family and then that being the root
of miss marvel is that in the comic that kamala
means um marvel is that like uh i mean i feel
like if it really means that then it just really
just changed that like yeah in this universe
uh i don't remember it being mentioned and now
i feel like a bad fan but i don't remember that
because that moment felt really new and special
to me yes i'm sure it is but it might have been
like issue one that was yeah i mean eight or nine
years ago uh for me reading it but i do think that
it was really smart to make it about her ancestry
in a different way like it's beautiful that it's a
translation of her own name and like that moment
of glee where she shares with carol danvers and
then it's her name like all of that is about
heritage all that is about ancestry about culture
this show thrived on family ancestry culture
action hearts and then the movie the show
landed with this great you know heist uh
home yes like you know all of that really
worked the action worked for me there was a
couple times brother coming around too dude
the moment the kid rode the bike by on the fire
extinguisher i was like i wish i had seen the show
in high school this would be my favorite show i
think that this this finale brought the two kinds
of shows together that they were doing impossibly
like how did the show balance those tones
yeah it's like some stuff i mean i don't even know
like there's nothing i'm sure if i slowed down and
was like what what can i critique i got no notes
man uh i i'm sure there's stuff uh but to me it
was just about the experience of this episode and
i thought this was a wonderful experience overall
i think loki is the most consistent um in one tone
and i think one division is the most impressively
bold as far as what it tried to accomplish at the
top this is probably the most impressive balance
of tones like it does the most different stuff and
that's saying something because one division is
literally a show that is sitcom tropes to open the
show like this show's insanely accomplished and i
loved when like everyone gathered around
to protect her at the end so to stand by
yes to stand by wither and you've said several
times that miss marvel in a lot of ways is like uh
what would you say spider-man so that's what
he says silverade spider-man has a lot of this
really cool he protects his town personally he's
got a lot of family elements his friends me a lot
he's always the underdog chasing balancing school
and work and being spider-man all of that to me is
what makes spider-man so approachable everyone can
understand like i can't do all of these things at
once and i've got this stress spider-man's
us to me what i love about kamala khan is
those silver age spider-man tropes made sense to
me because i identified with all of those things
including being like a straight white dude kamala
khan made all those things make sense to me and
i've never been a girl a person of color um
i'm not religious at all so i've never had
any religious uh persecution or or judgments so it
was really interesting to read those comics and be
like oh i get 90 of this world but the extra 10
means so much for me because i don't understand
any of this context but i still identify yeah
and that's so special and so hard to accomplish
then this [__] show did it yeah and they to my
understanding they honor the comics pretty well
it felt like the comics how so in the end even
zoe being a good girl again yeah so he teams up
i do like that that that at the very end of this
that the powers do come from her with within her
yeah ultimately um because i mean even though
the show already established that prior
very shang chi like which had the ten rings
thing too in here there's rings out there
when they tell you how phase four all connects
i can't wait dude i think the rings uh that
chongqi wares are made by fastos and i think the
bangle she wears is made by fastos and i think
that all of them haven't established that yet but
they're about to they're about to they're about to
go first they're kevin feige he's going to get
he's going to be like yo fast brian's tyrion
comes out and he's just making stuff and then i
then i come out on stage and it's dinner and i'm
like also expert oh [__] that would be cool see
you at comic-con on stage uh i didn't catch who
directed this one the original the the homies the
fans of the show the two uh that's the brothers
yeah or their brothers they're just best friends
the reject nation fans yeah uh you get their style
here it's pretty prevalent i thought they did a
really good job with the action and i think that
they also provided moments that were more menacing
than previous episodes like there was some real
dramatic heft within the action scenes at times
like especially when comrad is going through all
these internal moments of which which path do i
go down and dealing with the feelings of his mom
knowing that she's dead i really liked
those action scenes a lot where they
the film would go into slow motion mode and then
you'd see kamala like trying to process this
they had a lot of good visual body language
just between just in the action scenes as you're
watching these motives either increase you know
especially when it comes to kamala who moments
before was about to you know kiss komron and then
now here when she's making the decision to like
like i like how a lot of it just wasn't spoken for
example when the dodc guy's in the bathroom and
he's about to attack uh she he's about to attack
him and she decides to protect him like you could
feel this yeah this gap happening between them
and the way they shot him in those scenes where it
got extreme close up and the sweat and the agony
and the suffering like there was a lot that was
actually the first time their style reminded me
of what they did in bad boys in a very positive
way mixed with their style choices here yes i was
thinking uh yeah this stylistically is i i like
their work so much and i gotta include they're
gonna include better music this time around
badass rap music there was so much cool stuff
in this tonally and it built out a world that
feels really special like i i said when chongqing
ended this is the thing i want a sequel to most
in the mcu miss marvel's second like i think of
anything we've seen post endgame this is the world
i want to dive deeper into along with chungchi
yeah and you guys know i love eternals you yell
at me all the time but like this is what i want to
see i want to invest more in kamala khan's world
and i can't wait for not only does miss marvel 2
give or captain marvel to the marvels give me hope
for captain marvel because i love the character of
captain marvel in the comic books most of the time
i love brie larson most the time captain marvel
the movie didn't work for me but nia de costa who
directed candyman with tiona paris whose spectrum
in captain marvel in juan division that duo was
so incredible and the visuals need acosta used in
handyman all of those things give me so much hope
already for the marvels and then this
show just put the marvels like you combine
what i am hopeful for with the director of the new
duo and this show ending and how this landed like
i think the marvels is maybe in my top three most
anticipated marvel properties going forward now
i really liked the delivery that brie larson
did in that one little one yeah i was like
i don't know i was like i like free larsen
i wasn't a big fan of her performance in
captain marvel and i usually think pretty
large is a pretty damn good actress yeah
so i don't know there's something about that
moment that just felt very natural to me
yeah it wasn't something i was really saying no
no we both had a moment of like this is nice yeah
yeah i liked it i liked it i i like this version
and i like the costume i like that it feels more
like i wonder who directed that scene wonderful
it might be nina costa well i thought that the
um i think that this episode overall was just a
great it really hit the landing the family stuff
with the emotional beast i'm so sorry
huh no it's okay because we love john
it's usually like ah you did someone talks i'm
usually i'm usually conducting of like yeah
you took now you talk now i talk or something
like but when you're conducting you're telling
yourself the time to talk so instead i'm
like but i have things to say like i'm just
okay i just want to apologize but uh you were
saying about freelancers can you catch yourself
with that because then someone might say that here
in the comments but just so you know i'm like i
don't care bring coy here to talk i like least
talking i have to do the better off i am around
he's already done it i'm done three girls in
charge checked out man i uh i feel like the family
stuff to open the episode was genius and then that
re-established what the tone of the first half of
the show was right and then by the time you got to
where the moments ago events had happened you're
like oh right that's what this show is and then
it gave us all new stuff like this is a master
class in finale it wraps up so many story lines
it introduces new ideas it gives you action drama
heart it gives you all the characters you've loved
reminds you of something you'd forgotten about
and then it launches the next thing like this
every issue i've had with phase four has been
when creative freedom sacrifices the integrity
of characters this is how you do it this show is
stylistically [__] dope this show introduces
new characters this show gives you a brand new
world to invest in the characters you
just met and makes you love them and
it doesn't sacrifice the mcu while still building
it out this is what i want out of these movies
i was going to say several
things along those lines okay
um yeah uh they did family stuff and uh powers and
mutation was and they set up things right that's
what you said right yeah you had a good checklist
here i did i said those words in a similar order
i think that they what because in the first
episodes that's when they were doing very
stylistic with it's like scott pilgrim influences
right and then here i felt like they really found
kind of a more unique look that wasn't just
clearly inspired by scott pilgrim yeah and
i think it at times did kind of remind me of a
comic panel i thought the colors really popped
well like i noticed when comrade walked out into
where all the cops are everything was blue and
that's his power that's his power looking like
it's like this is his power position right now
everything's blue before he's even attacked
anyone his clothes are blue his powers are
blue the lighting's blue everything around him
is blue until it they i think they use a lot of
great illumination with the power sets yeah and i
thought the powers actually looked pretty neat in
this one i know that people sometimes the visual
effects can be a little bit wonky but i really do
this whole talk about visual effects ours has just
made me go i want to appreciate what they do more
because especially in such a crunch time because
marvel's like we'd have none of the well every
studios like we'd have none of this without
them it's like mainly warner brothers yeah
let's attack them while we're in the moment you
know what i feel like that's what we're talking
about i was trying to think of a studio that's
like defunct and i couldn't really like be sure
you know man yeah you know 8 24 with their garage
struggling having a hard time columbia house
yeah we did what was the one that
produced terminator corona oh no
we should wrap this video cannon with a cannon
c-a-n-o-n iconic colors it was like yeah
where you can go down to coco all right guys
what did you think about this finale um we
got to get coy to theorize about some [__] you
guys want to see another comic corner that's been
birthed from this moment that would be amazing
but look before we wrap this up let's do it
let me do one they don't even patronize
me i just love them oh i heard about eric
horseman what a nice guy we talked
about him last time you pick a name
craig do that thing with you
and let me know what it's doing gabriel shout
out gabriel gabriel you are lovely i like your
double use of hay you are the sponsor of the
day i appreciate your zeal i appreciate your
name and i appreciate the fact that you may or
may not be named after an angel of vengeance
it's good it's a good thing to be named that is
a great thing to be named after it's like you're
doing vengeance for us by being at our patreon
page by supporting us your protector i assume
they go by gabe but i wonder if they ever go by
brielle i think it's gab gab gab i've never been
a brielle but it's a kind of a cool name it sounds
like literary like real have you ever met a gab
they want to kill themselves thank you it hasn't
gone well for them i've met some games never a
brielle or a gab though why do we shorten names
so weird why is why is robert bob his last name
i don't know if i could say his last name do you
want it like legally or pronounce it i don't know
i think it's french i don't want to be
it's not like we're reading his email out
it sounds like the what's the song that goes i'll
be bulletproof who's that artist that wasn't a lot
of rap that didn't sound like a rap to me no
i'll be bullied proof is that like a edm thing
yeah yeah that does look like that is that
the thing you're singing that's you you're
bulletproof you're trying to tie it back into him
you're bored i don't know gabriel like an angel of
vengeance is bulletproof koi's never kicked
off a shout out and this is where it's gone
poorly all right bye everyone thanks gabriel